all right guys
bang bang i've got justin here dude so
excited to do this thank you so much for
uh for coming on
likewise i'm glad you found my uh just
by bitcoin tweet
and uh it finally connected us after we
have a lot of mutual friends
i know i feel like it's uh jeremy
gardner and a bunch of these people have
been like dude you guys gotta talk you
gotta talk and i've just been uh
lazy so uh here we are like we're gonna
not lazy not lazy
you're you're busy man you're you're
you're spreading the the gospel
uh on on behalf of you know all of us so
we appreciate it
i haven't told this story yet on the
podcast but i was in a a lift the other
day
and uh all of a sudden the driver
started pitching me like
hardcore like religious you know god
takes people out of your life
because uh he's trying to teach you
something and like you know not the
conversation you want to have with the
lyft driver
on a quick 12-minute trip uh and so
about halfway through i said hey man
uh that sounds great uh there's this guy
satoshi though
and my wife was with me and she was just
shaking her head like dude shut up
how how often does that happen with your
wife in a public setting
there's two uh eye rolls one is uh hey
like really shut up and the other is
just like you're annoying and i pretty
much now can decipher the difference so
uh so we're good
all right same with my my my girlfriend
as well whenever i talk about this stuff
so yeah you
you know the feeling i get it let's talk
about your background you got this crazy
background uh you pretty much did
everything you weren't supposed to do
from normal standards to become a dj
uh just tell us a story real quick yeah
absolutely so i
i went to college to study finance i was
thinking about going into asset
management all my friends were you know
went on to go work for morgan stanley or
goldman or ended up in tech so i kind of
had this background in finance tech
and then of course my passion which was
music when i was growing up i
decided that i would you know go work
for a bank and then when i'm 40 years
old i get to pursue my passion of music
and then it ended up flipping the
opposite direction
where i started releasing a bunch of
music on facebook and soundcloud back
when those were the kind of main
platforms for sharing music
and a couple things went viral on
youtube all of a sudden
some fraternities at other schools
wanted to pay me 750 bucks to come play
their basement
and that's how i made alcohol money in
college um when i was a freshman and
sophomore just djing around the country
some more things went viral i attracted
attention of an agency
an agent who's now with caa which is one
of the big agencies and
he helped me build my career to the next
level and play festivals like
edc ultra um you know
electric zoo in new york if you're
familiar and all types of stuff like
that and
i decided my junior year of college that
it would be the best decision to
drop out and take a leave of absence and
luckily enough the business school at
washington university
where i went they said that i could keep
my full merit scholarship
for seven years if i ever wanted to come
back my parents couldn't really say no
and when i was 19 or 20 i embarked on
this journey as a dj
and built you know use technology and
social media to build my following
organically
while maintaining uh being an
independent artist
so i read that you got this idea because
you went to sweden
and when you were there you kind of got
exposed to electronic music
and and uh it's interesting to me
because
i my thought was always like oh if you
have a specific genre
of music that you're a dj or a performer
or whatever
uh you just grew up your whole life and
like that was your thing
that wasn't your kind of past so maybe
talk a little bit about
what was it when you discovered that
type of music that just was like hey i
want to go do this absolutely yeah so i
grew up
singing playing piano playing drums
playing guitar and i was kind of a
one-man band i was making folk music
in my dorm room that's kind of what i
was doing in my free time when i wasn't
working on schoolwork stuff
and there were there were a group of djs
that played our college concert
um called white panda and they were
jumping around making mashups
and that's when i kind of decided well
you know in the school budget
it shows that they got paid they got
paid 11 grand to perform
i said huh i should maybe like explore
how to be an electronic artist
and it wasn't really that big in the u.s
yet and my my friend johann who
is now in sales and training at morgan
stanley um invited me out to sweden
and that's kind of when i explored this
dance music world and learned about
avicii at the time you know was one of
my biggest inspiration
inspirations and i was lucky to have met
him and
you know that changed my life in the
sense that i decided instead of
channeling this musical effort into a
band like more folk format why not
channel it into this electronic format
that's growing so quickly i genuinely
love the music
so that's kind of how it all began and
it eventually evolved into you know me
turning down a job opportunity at
blackrock to pursue
the dj thing full-time and it really
took off organically it's just the
effort that i put in
um to learn the craft yeah my favorite
part of your story is that a professor
uh told you to drop out which is uh oh
yeah pretty pretty crazy because i don't
think most people think of their uh
you know university professor being like
hey man i think you should go take a
shot at this like what was that like
and he he was the chair of the economics
department and we are actually still
very close friends today i see him
at least once a year he's been he's come
out to red rocks in colorado which is a
huge venue
that i've played a couple times and um
he's been like my biggest supporter from
day one and
in his mind he saw the financials and he
saw the momentum that was happening
organically
and i i had him sit down with my parents
to convince them finally to let me do
this
because in his mind the opportunity cost
was just too high
for me to not capitalize on this
momentum and the downside risk
was that i would just go back to school
if it didn't work out so what i lose it
lose a couple years
you know if i was to go into the banking
world so i go to the banking world when
i'm 23 24 instead of
21 22 the skill set wouldn't change and
and
it was too big like i said too big of an
opportunity cost to not take so
finally we did it and and he's been a
huge supporter since and
i call him for advice all the time and
that's the nice thing about washu and
the network that i created there
you know it's cool that some of my
friends have gone on to establish really
cool companies like open door
um i mentioned you earlier but you know
my friend jd started open door with
keith's boy and
he was i played in his frat basement i
think that was the first placement i
ever played
so i've kind of always had ties to the
tech world into the business world and
um i treat my career a lot like a
business
in that you know we we like to utilize
all the tools that technology has
provided to get
my stuff out there yeah you really use
technology to kind of build an audience
and a true
fan base talk about that and kind of
where did that idea come from like that
was not necessarily the most
popular uh thing to be doing uh you know
a couple of years ago and so
how did you come across that idea yeah
so this is about a decade ago
in this weird time in music where it was
between
napster and torrenting itunes
and then eventually spotify kind of
stole the entire market share
but in the middle there was this weird
time where just the discovery process
wasn't via torrents and wasn't via
itunes it was via music blogs and via
social media
and facebook was like the primary
facebook and soundcloud were the primary
tools of sharing music across the
internet
as the social media world began to
materialize
so what we used to do what i used to do
is we'd post things
to my facebook page which at the time if
you liked if you liked the facebook page
you saw everything
so there was no threshold and
distribution back then so we would you
know upload stuff to soundcloud and post
it to facebook and
it would grow organically um and also
youtube
where like people would just share it
and because there was no threshold and
you didn't have to pay to play at the
time it was so new
it just reached so many people and
one special moment i i did this mashup
called all night long and the usc
snowboarding team did a trick video to
it on youtube and it like
had millions of views overnight and
that's the video that some of the
fraternities that eventually booked me
to play their
their basements later um that that's the
that's the video they quoted you know
how they found me through youtube
through the internet and so these were
like
valuable tools for any artist to break
at a time when otherwise you'd have to
sign a really aggressive record deal
and record deals are very predatorial
they you know a record label does two
things they provide liquidity
for an artist to pursue their dream and
they also provide distribution
in 2020 now and over the past 10 years
that's changed you can source capital
from a lot of different places as an
artist
and we've i've reinvested in myself from
all my touring revenue we reinvested in
content creation and whatnot
and then so on the liquidity side
there's other tools for an artist to
achieve that
then on the distribution side you have
the internet and platforms like yours
you know whether it's twitter or podcast
or
tick tock or whatever it might be and
artists have this unique ability now
to not rely on these legacy systems and
to create businesses for themselves they
just have to recognize
that while the creative side of the
brain has to be creative and has to
create
it's it's important to maintain this
logical side of the brain that says
how are we going to strategically get
all this stuff out there to the world
and get people excited about it
yeah and the idea that a dj is a
business right i don't think a lot of
people think of this they think of just
oh you get your salary
and that's it talk a little bit about
kind of how you've structured the
business and what does that look like
from
the various revenue streams and how you
think about growing the business and
kind of more of a business owner type
mentality
absolutely you know i think i think
because my background is
from the financial world and at least
that's what i studied i approached it
that way i don't know if everyone does
but but there are a lot of dj's that are
friends of mine
like like steve aoki for instance in
tiesto that have always treated
their creative space as a business and
that ultimately helps them reach
more people so the idea first is that i
run a team
right any startup has a team you know
the most challenging part
of any startup is finding people to help
you build your vision
that are the best people at what they do
and so building a team is
as an artist and as a musician is
probably the most important thing you
can do
when you have any momentum so like step
one is find a way to
get momentum which is it's really hard
to pass level one for a lot of people
but a lot of people do pass level one
they have a viral tick tock video they
have
something that performs well on the
internet after that it's picking the
right people to work with
and having that entrepreneurial mindset
to see who can create value and where
is extremely important so you know one
of the people that i brought on early in
my career kevin
he runs my social platforms you know but
but it's a collaborative effort it's not
like he just
it's like i'd give it to him to run it
no like we work on the messaging we work
on the content we work on it together
and it's
he's become a really close friend of
mine we've worked together for seven
years so in that sense
you know i have to deal with teams and
then i have him interacting with my
management team which is comprised of
two people
um a day-to-day manager and then a
strategic manager who's also a music
lawyer
and they kind of are the glue of all
these different concepts that we have
whether it's a song release or a
performance or a brand partnership
right and so i put these teams together
and we all brainstorm how we execute
these different parts of my business
so it is i've always said that being an
artist is very similar
to being you know not just a business
owner but actually being a startup
because you have to scale really quickly
and you have to you know
you have to look at all these different
ways that you can monetize and then in
my case i reinvest all that money in
content creation and production
like lasers and fire at my shows it's
really expensive to do that stuff
um our last tour i mean our last tour
quest cost
mid six figures just on the actual
production and the lights
um to create these experiences for fans
that they'll never forget
and so in order to you know produce
those kind of shows
i need to continue to find other places
to monetize to reinvest in the business
so it's really
you know being a dj is kind of unique in
that
there is this high cost of perform like
the performances are really expensive to
put on these like big light shows
and it's a little bit different than a
band um where it's more about the sound
experience and less about like the crazy
lights and the led screens and whatnot
though that is shifting a bit these days
there's a lot of crossover there
um but yeah so i've always treated my
career as a business and i try to
separate
the creative mind from the business mind
so that i i can still make stuff that
people enjoy
yeah and then how do you think about
like obviously the music uh i think
people would say okay you make music
that there's like streaming platforms
there's the ip around the music
and you can go touring but it's also
this weird thing of like there's a
celebrity factor there's kind of other
things that you can be doing
have you kind of thought through where
the line is for a dj like is a dj still
a dj and that's all they can do or does
it kind of blend into more of like
you're a creator you're uh influencer
you're you know whatever you're
um kind of labeled de jour today
it's a really interesting question um
i've always had the perspective that
a dj in 2020 is a musician a producer
and a personality i don't
i don't love the word influencer because
my following is
mostly on on spotify it's not on other
platforms why because people
listen to me they don't necessarily care
as much about
products that i promote and like taking
selfies and doing things like that no
like the way that people interact with
me creatively is
through my on you know through my music
which is my form of messaging
there are a lot of artists that have
built like huge brands like marshmallow
for instance who is
purely you know influencer figurehead
icon
but a lot of djs are more like they have
huge followings that are really
dedicated
but they don't have the biggest social
platform so an example of this is um
rufus du sol who you know headlining
coachella are we're supposed to this
year they did last year i forget
um roofs just all huge electronic
artists they only have three million
monthly listeners on spotify they have
like less than a million on instagram
and yet
their fan base is so dedicated and so as
an artist it's about balancing like
there's something about being a musician
that's different than i think any other
type of influencer
in it's in the connection that you build
on a very deep level with your fan
and so that's where you see a lot of
like
artists that may have smaller numbers
like i don't have a huge instagram
following it's like 300 something
thousand
which is big but it's not that big
whereas my spotify following is
you know two million it's like a whole
different number and and so
my goal is to how do i make those two
million people that are listening
feel the most and that's like my number
one goal at the same time
doing partnerships with other brands and
exploring other creative avenues is
really interesting as well
so i work with a lot of tick talkers on
dance videos to help promote my music
because
a lot of young people are watching these
dance videos and so it's something that
we're thinking about
as i you know create new content but
yeah i think the line is blurred
for for a dj right now it's not you know
the conventional notion of like
a wedding dj or a disc jockey so to
speak we're really
the best identity to associate with a
quote-unquote dj we're really
music producers with you know
public-facing identities that people
hopefully
can relate to i think that's like a
concise way of saying it
yeah and so obviously the business uh
completely changes you
are used to kind of flying around every
single day touring you know meeting fans
putting on these
uh expensive shows and then covet hits
and basically the world goes on lockdown
what was kind of the changes you made
and how did you think about
how you spent your time and kind of how
the business would evolve
yeah man that's that's the most
important question of the day um
i you know i've said this to a lot of
people i i started when i was 19 and i'm
29 i'm gonna be 30 in a couple months
here in january
and after a decade of being on the road
i have to say i'm thankful
for a little bit of a break because i
probably wouldn't have taken one
i want to make the fans happy i want to
be out there i have such a love for
giving energy
back to the world with music but in that
process
you know i tell people i don't get paid
to dj i get paid to put my body through
hell
my travel schedule is pretty insane gone
from like in
in a one week period from vegas to new
york new york to tokyo tokyo
to philippines philippines to jakarta
jakarta to san francisco san francisco
to hawaii and hawaii back to vegas like
all in a period of
like 13 14 days or whatever it was you
know like
that's that's a typical day in life and
so living that life for 10 years
of my young years and then it's shutting
off in march
like that at first i was really
depressed
for like a couple months i couldn't
really motivate myself to do anything i
didn't
really know what to do i had all this
extra time and as time went on
i started to realize that you know this
opening came
like it's pretty suddenly and you know
i've had an interest in
in the cryptocurrency space for a very
long time i've been involved in that
space for a long time because of my
background in finance because i've
always been
fascinated with this idea of
disintermediating the entertainment
industry and
giving power back to creators and so you
know
come march or sorry come may june
i re-explored the non-fungible token
nft space and i started working with my
art director
same art director that does all the
visuals for my shows that you see on the
screen
behind me we started working
collectively really hard
on creating digital virtual audio
experiences
and that's been kind of my focus focus
for the past couple months
you know producing unique music that no
one's heard before
and combining with unique visuals that
my art director mike designs
and issuing it in the form of an nft
and you know it's it's fascinating and
you know this because you've been very
heavily involved in the space
there's a lot of value in a digital
certificate
of authenticity for art it's no
different than a physical piece of art
where a painter has spent hours and
hours and hours of time designing it and
then one person
gets to have the painting right you can
still find the painting on google you
can still find those picassos and those
andy warhol's on google the amount of
time that we put into this digital art
it's never been valued
as something that's scarce it's always
been oh it's it's media it should be
spread everywhere
and so this this notion of spinning that
on its head and saying
well everyone can see it but there's
only one owner there's a lot of value in
that
exclusive media consumption is really
interesting and so we've both been
exploring that world
and it's been a great new source of
income at a time when
my the touring world is completely shut
off and i'm like
what now and and so how did you first
come across bitcoin or crypto
what was that kind of yeah we can we can
rewind yeah experience yeah yeah
yeah so um i'll try to go through that
really quickly as well um
i met the winklevoss twins in mexico on
spring break
in 2013 or so right after i'd started it
was with avicii actually i was opening
for vichy at a club
and um just befriended them they're
awesome guys
obviously their whole story finding
bitcoin and ibiza right they love dance
music
they invited me to stay with them in la
for a little bit of time um
it was like during grammy week the
following year and that's when they were
building gemini
um i don't think it was launched yet and
and my memory is a little
not not 100 clear here but they were
talking on a call about it and i just
overheard about it
asked a couple questions and bought you
know some bitcoin back in 2014 put it
away still have it
still have that bitcoin from back then
um and
it was like my first realization that
the financial system was so flawed and i
had a background in
in traditional you know finance right
and so i realized that there's like
three main value propositions to
cryptocurrency
that both exist in the financial world
and also apply
to the music world number one banking
beyond banks there are so many people
that don't have access to storing value
they've worked hard in their lives and
they have no means of actually saving
that value that they've created because
the next day their government could
print more of it
they could you know anything could
happen and and even in places like india
it's so hard to even get access to a
bank account right
these are things that we don't think
about a lot in the united states so that
was like the first major value
proposition that
ranked some alarms in my head and i was
like this is really important i have to
pay attention to this
the second thing was value transfer in a
frictionless permissionless way
so i had an experience where i was
making a real estate investment
and my local bank of america branch
didn't have someone with high enough
authorization to send a wire
and we had to wait three days to move
this money
to for me to make this investment and
then on ethereum
send money around 45 seconds if you if
you spend enough gas
and so i was like wow and i can send it
anywhere in the world and on a weekend
right like you can't send money around
you can't send a wire on a weekend this
is crazy
how like it's 2020 how does this not
exist yet or at the time you know 2015
2016.
and then the final thing i realized is
there are all these rent-seeking
middlemen in music and in entertainment
and in all type
all forms of the world that take a fee
on things they probably shouldn't be
taking fees on because the internet
makes
the relationship between the consumer
and the creator or the consumer and the
supplier
way more direct and so you know
even in the music space with royalties
right we have all these contracts
there's a lag in payout from spotify
then you have to like individually
invoice
every person that participated in a song
and they get a percentage of the
royalties and it's like never right
there's always an accounting issue
load all that up into a smart contract
and have the money funnel out
automatically
every day like this this is stuff that
should already exist right it really
should but
the regulatory environment makes it
difficult so
you know i've always just had a passion
for exploring this stuff and thinking
about
how i can participate in the story of
what we both know will revolutionize not
just you know the financial world but
the entertainment world and so many
other things
yeah it's really really crazy to me that
um
you know when you hear it and it's and
it hits
and you're like oh wait this is why it's
so valuable people go from i didn't
understand
any of this to immediately up to speed i
mean it's just you just get pulled down
the rabbit hole right
and so uh you obviously were able to do
that you learned from two of uh to the
best people to do it and uh and had the
most skin in the game
uh and cameron and tyler uh and then
when did you kind of come across the
nfts and this
idea of digital art um and kind of
things outside of just
uh money and bitcoin yeah um that's kind
of
the the the best uh the best place to
kind of explain where i am today
so i had a couple of interesting
adventures through crypto i tried a lot
of things
experimented in a decentralized finance
space which i'm sure other speakers in
the podcast have spoken with you about
there's a lot of really interesting i
call them experiments that are going on
and experiments are the best way to beta
test ideas that will work
to the masses and one venue
that has always historically been
the the fastest onboard of the
mainstream to a new technology is art
you know it's like it's porn and it's
art like that's that's what people say
right like
you know so uh it's really interesting
that you know
through my journeys in cryptocurrency
there's there's always been this kind of
huge barrier to entry
whether it's the process of buying
bitcoin buying ethereum or it's you know
using metamask which is you know for
someone new very difficult
um and people don't really have the
patience to learn about it
unless they really want to learn about
it right so um
art became a way i had this realization
only a couple months ago you know i'm an
artist i make music
but art can be exclusive art can be a
way to onboard the mainstream
to the digital currency ecosystem and
what's interesting about it is if you
bet on an artist like there hasn't
really been a way for you to bet on
on an artist you believe in there hasn't
been a way for you to invest in your
favorite art
you know without i mean just buying a
painting there isn't really you buy
merch from a musician
you support them by seeing a show you
stream their music but when you're
streaming their music
you're not like thinking yourself oh i'm
supporting that artist by streaming
their music no it's one directional it's
like i get to enjoy this music
you don't have a relationship with the
artist so we started experimenting with
nfts and we launched
our first batch with a company called
block party that i've worked with
and advised for a couple years and what
i noticed is it creates such a personal
relationship with collectors
people who are buying this digital art
this this limited edition digital art
and they feel so much closer to you as
an artist because they're participating
in this very limited product
that they know i've spent tons of time
on and i have we put a lot of effort and
care
into every piece that we do and all
those people that bought
you know our first round of nfts which
sold out in like three hours which was
crazy
um i followed them on twitter i talked
to them and they were and then
we sent them the full version of the
unreleased song that we used to make the
r
in an email after the fact and people
were going crazy wow i have this blouse
home that no one else has heard
and that got me thinking about this idea
that
media doesn't have to be available to
everyone
media can be exclusive and there's value
in people having access to a song or a
piece of art or
even just ownership of that art there's
so much value there that's just
never been explored before because we've
been trained that music and art should
be widespread
so this is what got me into like doing
more nft stuff so we did this first
launch
and we did another launch with nifty
gateway following and our pieces sold
out in 14 seconds
we did 21 000 in 14 seconds
and then we did another 21 000 at
auction for the one piece that was in
the auction
and that's when i was like this is real
there's real demand here people
are really excited about having a piece
of digital culture that i made
and being the true owners of it and then
the more people that get to
see this art people are like oh well why
can't i just rip it and put it on my
screen
well you can someone comes over your
house you have a digital frame
and someone says what's that you're like
oh it's this art that i like okay
it's this art that i own i supported
this artist
in making this piece that's on my wall
people want to be able to say that
and so i've really started diving into
this idea of like what it means to
create
content that might be available to
everyone but that is exclusive to a few
and it already exists in the physical
world i don't want to rant too much
about this but like
when you buy a pair of yeezys a fake
pair of yeezys and a real pair of easies
they do the exact same thing
but do you really want the fake ones no
the same thing with like an instagram
verification check mark people
love to know that they're verified on
instagram and there's this whole market
for buying
verification like back when instagram
let people do it people would put up
offers
to get other people to verify them and
that was like a common form of social
digital scarcity the check mark
people wanted that [ __ ] you know and so
this this concept of owning a piece of
digital art is not that foreign
especially from the gaming world and
that's a whole other you know we can
that's
a whole conversation in and of itself
it's not that foreign but it feels kind
of weird to someone new and just like
with bitcoin with other cryptocurrencies
once it clicks you're like aha
i get this i want to support the artists
that are making digital art because
they're spending
just as much time on the digital art as
a physical artist is spending my
painting
yeah and it's pretty crazy to me too
because
part of the digital art like if you just
compare what i'll call analog art or
traditional art to
digital art there's a number of
superiorities
uh that you can point out in terms of
the digital art right there can um
you can change it you can um you know
kind of programmatically do things you
can have motion you can have sound you
can do all these kind of things
i think that we've just kind of touched
the very start
where people are saying oh i took like a
regular piece of art but now it's
digital and i can prove that i own it
that to me is like important but it's
not the most important thing it's not
the whole story right
whereas with you like you're now talking
about sound
motion artistic kind of creativity so
talk through a little bit about just
like
how you think about um you know to me
it's like uh
being a non-artist like multiple inputs
to the experience
right of viewing the yard or kind of
experiencing it
you've guided just a couple of these
conversations in the past haven't you
you're very good at guiding this i was i
was just about to go there and i
appreciate that you mentioned
that you know art in the physical space
can only be experienced in one way
you see it art in the digital space can
be experienced in a multitude of ways
and you can add sound which is something
that is so special
where my art director and i are
literally creating audio reactive art
it's not something that's possible
i mean it is possible in the physical
world arguably you know but but not to
the same extent
so when we think about what we're
creating
we want to create these experiences for
people that ultimately capture
memories for them and right now it
exists on these platforms like
you know nifty gateway and block party
and super rare
but in the future i imagine you know
when the world opens back up
you go to a music festival and if you
come to my stage
and you see the visuals that are on my
screen behind the stage
if you were in there at that moment you
can take your smartphone out scan a qr
code
and you get a limited edition nft that
is your proof of memory of that of
experiencing that
and that's so powerful it's incredibly
powerful i mean that's one way that it
manifests but there are other ways that
it manifests as well
you know when we did my project that i
worked on i did a
crypto music festival project in 2018 we
created an uh it wasn't an nft it was
just a limited erc
20 token um we just made 50 we just
mentioned 50 tokens and if you found me
at the festival
it was like a scavenger hunt i was in
the audience i was walking around if you
found me
and you'd scan my phone and you get a
limited edition wow badge
and people were so stoked about it we've
like barely scratched
the surface of how digital art can
interact with reality
and that's something that i'm i'm
exploring really heavily now and
getting really excited about but like
you said it's it's the first type of art
that's truly multi-dimensional
and it's been kind of devalued in the
sense that
people think you could just go on the
internet and find it but no um
the fans and the listeners and the
people that appreciate art they actually
really want to be
the owners of it they want to own it and
we're just starting to see these trends
um and i mean you you personally i mean
you've supported an artist
like fuocious who's exploded in
popularity who's very talented
and is just being creative out of there
you know uh i think he's out of his
parents house he's moving out now but
out of his parents house here in vegas
and and like that's incredible that
resource for an artist
is is so valuable at a time like this
when there are a few ways for artists to
monetize so
props to you for for showing support to
the art world yeah look i i am a
i'm a huge believer and here's the
argument i always say to people is like
uh the wealthiest people in the world
love art right they love art because
there's a creative aspect to it and they
love art because it's a great store of
value
right and and if they're intelligent
about from a financial investment
standpoint it can appreciate
right and so uh if you think that
traditional art has all of those things
in the analog world
what the hell do you think's gonna
happen in the digital world and we're
talking about a target
opportunity right now that's like
literally measured in the single digit
you know millions of dollars you're
telling me that's not going to be worth
billions if not over a trillion dollars
in the future
of course it is so funny you mentioned
the art market i think is over 80
billion annually there's a 80 billion in
art sales globally annually in in fiscal
art
and i'm lucky to have some connections
to the physical art world because i'm a
musician and the dj
and i've already had discussions you
know not disclosing particular
people but um one very very well-known
art collector and his gallerist
is already looking to procure some
pieces for me digitally
and one of the top four galleries in new
york
is still new to this concept
but wants to help me bring it to the
physical space so that the older
collector community understands it and
we have things like these samsung
digital frames
which look awesome i mean right now
they're not on but i actually have
pieces displayed on screen behind me
and right next to them i have a piece of
physical art right and so like
there's no reason why people in their
homes and in their personal spaces they
can't display the the art that they're
proud of and some of this digital art
like you said before it can bend
dimension in ways that physical art
can't
um there's something called um and i
don't know if you you know about this
too much but
have you heard of op art no what is that
oh dude uh it's gonna it's gonna be fun
to for you to look it up after this it's
optical illusion art where it looks like
it's moving but it's actually a still
image
it's really difficult to achieve that
with paint with with paint
and with physical products so there are
a couple of artists that do this really
well
um but it's like black and white mostly
but it literally looks like it's moving
but it's a still image and it's it's
like unbelievable what
how technology can add dimension to the
art world
yeah what is kind of your goal in the
art world are you going to uh
one day turn around and no longer be a a
dj and only an artist or
kind of what's the uh what's the master
plan here
yeah so i think that's a great question
man you're so good at these follow-ups
it's incredible um
i i just had this conversation with a
friend um i'm gonna be 30
right in thinking about my life i've
thought well
the last 10 years of my life were
incredible i got to make music i got to
travel the world
meet a lot of fans play a lot of music
and i'm still going to do that in the
future but
i like sleeping and i like being living
on a normal schedule so
instead of doing 120 shows a year i'm
going to scale it back to like maybe 40
or 50. and that's going to be great
the next 10 years i i'm thinking about
my legacy right like how can i
influence the music world in a way
that's you know that will really change
change people's lives and artists lives
especially like i've always been a huge
proponent of supporting young artists
and
new talent because they need that push
um
so i've kind of had three goals over the
next decade first goal
um continue to make music and push the
boundaries musically second goal
explore the you know digital art world
and
experiences digitally in in a way that
are are completely
new and exciting to to users and to to
listeners
create these new experiential
environments that like haven't ever
existed
in the past and of course leverage
blockchain technology to distribute and
to access that world
and the final thing that i'm working on
you know that we can chat about another
time
is giving the public the ability to
invest in music
um literally allowing the public to
provide liquidity to young artists
and bet on their success and participate
in the cash flows
that music generates which i think will
effectively disintermediate the entire
music business because if an artist can
go to their fans to raise money
and they can go to their fans for
distribution record labels don't really
need to exist the problem with that is
just that
there's securities implications there
that just need to be worked out but it's
only a matter of time before something
like that happens
so those are my kind of three missions
in the next decade continue to make
music
explore this digital art experiential
world via blockchain technology and also
you know give the public the means of
investing in music assets
i love it that's awesome uh before i let
you go ask the same two questions to
everybody
uh and then you get asked me when to
finish up the first one is what is the
most important book that you've ever
read
the intelligent investor why
it gave me perspective on how to manage
my capital long term in a way that i
hadn't had and i had probably only been
thinking short term
prior to reading that book and so it
gave me a way longer term perspective
and gives so many great historical
examples of really smart people that
made really bad investments
um and and that's great and i love like
seeing the history of it and it kind of
maps the future especially with what's
happening now so i would say that's one
of the most important books that i read
yeah
that's a great answer second question is
more fun aliens believer or non-believer
believer given given some uh some new
things that have come out
they've got to be out there and they're
probably way smarter than us so
not surprised that we don't know about
them they definitely know about us let's
hope that we find them they don't find
us oh boy
yeah you can ask me it's a good one
yeah uh you could ask me one question to
uh to wrap it up what you got for me
oh man uh who is your favorite
artist either in music or in the digital
art space right now
digital art ferocious obviously uh we've
been uh we we've been pretty clear that
uh that we're big fans there
and uh obviously commissioned a couple
of pieces and just generally think uh
it's everything about the story of the
artist the way that the artist kind of
builds a community
and engages with that community and then
the actual quality of the work right
so i think that uh uh there and then um
music on the music side
man i no matter what i i just gotta
stick with biggie
for for oh all right dude that's good
dude that's a good answer man that's a
good answer he even uh
yeah there's a lot of artists now that
are really great that you know i'm like
hey look
they're uh they're doing a good job but
uh but in terms of music if uh
that uh here's the gym that's what you
turn on i was gonna say that there's
basically uh
if i had a rattle off a bunch it's like
biggie nwa
jay-z you know you just go down the list
uh of
uh of a bunch of uh great artists but
those would those would definitely make
the list
so listen man thank you so much for
doing this i really appreciate it i
think people will
learn a lot and obviously uh you've got
kind of these parallel paths now both on
the on the music side and the art side
so uh
i'm cheering for you and we'll
definitely have to do this again in the
future yeah dude thanks thanks for
taking the time i've been a big fan
i love your tweets um appreciate your
support
of the community and uh and thanks for
having me on